A warm welcome to Björn Ulvaeus!
Did you notice how fat I was
on those pictures from Brighton?
From Brighton?
But you were thin as a line.
-Later on, yes, but back then?
-I've never thought about that.
-But I was.
-You were thin during the ABBA-years.
Not at the very beginning.
That was later on.
When we got home from Brighton,
after our victory...
I looked at myself in the mirror: "You
can't be a pop idol and look like that."
-ABBA became a sort of diet for you?
-Yes. And an efficient one at that.
-But then you got really thin.
-Right.
Was it because of stress or...?
No, no. There was this agreement
back then-
-that pop stars should
be thin as a thread.
-And still is today, I believe.
-Absolutely.
Were you on a special diet and stuff?
Well...
I don't really remember what I ate,
but I only ate a little.
But there was nothing else going on?
You weren't smoking or anything?
No. It was easier for our English
and American colleagues-
-because they had access
to some very nice drug-
-that made it easier for them not to eat.
But we were those safe Swedes,
who...
Two Swedish couples.
We weren't into those things...
But...
Having you here as a guest, one feels
like reminiscing ABBA and things.
But your memory isn't all that good,
is it?
It isn't, no.
At least not the episodic memory.
That memory that I envy
so many people-
-when you can go back in time
and feel how it felt-
-almost feel the smell of that memory.
I don't have that.
But that aside,
my memory is perfectly fine.
I talked about this in my radio program
a couple of years ago.
And this has grown, ever since,
on the internet, into:
"He suffers
from a serious memory loss."
And this has pursued me.
But it only concerns
that specific episodic memory.
-That emotional memory.
-Exactly.
-Do you have that type of memory?
-I guess I could go back...
I'm trying here. No, I can't.
Well, a little. A fragrance can
make me feel nostalgic.
No, but I mean - when you're able
to reenact a scene in your mind-
-and then feel the way you felt back
then, the odours, etc, etc.
But do you ever get nostalgic -
when we talk about ABBA, for instance?
No, I don't, actually. I wasn't...
Every one else is...
I don't wish I were still up on stage,
like Mick Jagger.
It was good while it lasted, so...
But I do look back on that time with joy.
But would you be able to,
theoretically speaking?
I don't think so.
If you asked Benny he'd say: "No!"
But do you have
one more "Mama Mia" in you?
Would you be able to write
"Dancing Queen" today?
I believe that the best pop music
is written by young people-
-when they're at the summit
of their creativity.
We all have such a period in our lives.
It only lasts about ten years.
Then you enter another kind
of creativity.
But we had that peak in question during
the 70's with ABBA.
But it's not as if you're resting
on your laurels, is it?
-Do you have that expression?
-"Lagrar", yes.
"Lagrar" in Swedish.
Because you're not, right?
-It depends on what you mean by that.
-You're very active.
You're a debater. You write columns.
And you're into all kinds of...
But that stuff doesn't take up too much
of my time.
-You are resting on your laurels, then?
-Yes, I suppose I am.
I'm privileged enough to do
whatever I'm interested in-
-and stimulates me. Stressing and
chasing things is pointless to me now.
-So, you don't need an alarm clock.
-Not really, no.
I try to set my meetings
at around 11 o'clock.
-What about you?
-Well, I have an alarm clock...
But I have someone who keeps waking me
up in the middle of the night, so...
-I have four.
-Four alarm clocks?
-I had four of them, yes.
-Yes, that's how it goes.
Have you... You're interested
in various topics-
-that have nothing to do with Abba
or music.
-Like most people.
-Yes. Societal issues.
And one of these themes is atheism.
-Like...
-Religion.
You're one of the co-publishers
of one of our next guests.
Where do you find the energy?
The person who did not get upset
by 9/11 is not born.
That's when I thought: "My god."
"Religion is on its way in again."
To a forum where it does not belong -
where we legislate, etc.
It was so sad, because it wasn't just
the islamists.
There was a crusader
on the other side of the Atlantic.
So, the whole situation turned
into this.
It felt like:
"Oh, it's coming back again."
All these centuries
after the Enlightenment-
-where we've been working so hard to
reach this secularized society of our's.
It was threatened. That's how it felt.
I can see now that this never happened.
But that's when my commitment started.
Is an atheist - as some people claim -
a person-
-who's just not been in a situation
where they've felt-
-that it would've been normal to turn
towards God?
I could imagine myself ending up
in such a situation-
-where my yearning for solace or help-
-gets so strong that I find myself
thinking: "Okay" - and give in.
But I'm not saying that there is no God,
because I don't know.
I'm just saying that I haven't found
sufficient reasons to believe otherwise.
Would you be able to pray?
If someone convinced me that there does
exist something to pray to - yes.
-What would you do...
-It's a difficult question.
Yes, but what... You must've looked
for solace at one point or another?
If my wife can't give me solace
in that situation-
-then I'll have to move on.
There's nothing else you can do.
And it works.
With time it all works out.
You would only turn to your wife
for solace?
Yes, she's the closest to thing
I would turn to.
But about this solace... People's need
for solace being so great-
-does not mean that there's an answer to
that solace-
-or that there is someone
who can solace you.
It only means that you have this strong
longing for solace-
-and for life not to end after death.
Is it...
Are you saying that you don't believe
in solace?
I think we should take responsibility
for our own lives.
And we only live once. And we should
take full responsibility for that.
But there's a lot of solace to be found
in a great song.
Yes, music offers a lot of solace.
That's a good way.
It's been great having you here.
We're going to meet one of your great
role models - dr Richard Dawkins.
He's a very famous atheist.
Please, welcome Agnetha Fältskog!